San Diego will tell us about algorithms
for detecting selection okay thank you
and I'd like to thank the organizers for
this wonderful meeting I think it's been
the talks have been particularly
insightful especially for someone like
me it was more an outsider to the
community so I think we are fortunate to
be in this era where we can see
evolution at work and my own interest in
the field started when some
collaborators of mine talked about some
of the experiments they were doing and
I'll take two examples to show sort of
the diversity of examples that we can
now deal with so in the first case they
had this very nice fly model where they
took a progenitor population and asked
what it would what would happen if we
reduce the oxygen in the chamber so so
they split it up into two parts one was
a control and the other they gradually
evolved under sort of low and low oxygen
till they reached four percent oxygen so
so that's significantly lower thing if
you want a kind of you know a different
view of how low that might be it's the
oxygen you would see if you were 12,000
feet above Everest so so at this point
you know most humans would be you know
pretty much not equal to breathe and die
and it took the Flies also many
generations to adapt and after about 40
or 50 generations aligned was
established where you could see that
there was some inherited change because
you can put them for a few generations
in normal oxygen and then put them back
in hypoxia and they do just fine so so
certainly the change is genetic and the
question was that if we sequenced the
genomes of these flies and in this case
they did not do it for individuals
because you have to serve amplify the
DNA but you just pull together
population and sequence them again in
triplicate in both the controls and
normal so they asked us if there is
regions where you can see that there was
some selective constraint being applied
so that was a very nice model with a lot
of controls and we were excited to work
on it second example
out sorry just to say one more thing
about the Flies you know the breeding
cycles about two weeks so 180
generations which is where the fly was
when they first sequenced it would take
us quite a ways back in human history of
course you know the evolution rates and
all are not the same so it's not a
direct comparison and the other thing is
that the Flies in spite of being very
distant do have homology with human
proteins and I think the second example
will will tell take us to a place where
we can actually use some of this
information so this is the second
example about is about humans living in
sort of hypoxic conditions up in the in
high altitudes this particular place is
not where we sampled the data were from
it's just a place that my student who
did most of the work happened to visit
and so he put up his own pictures these
are salt fields in Bolivia and you can
see him sort of trying to make a pile of
salt being young and I would say foolish
as he told it to me and then very soon
falling sick with acute mountain
sickness and he had it took him a couple
of days to recover and of case the way
he coped was by increasing the red blood
count in a cell so that he would have
enough oxygen and this is a good
short-term coping mechanism but it's
really bad if this is the way that
humans were to go because if you if you
have this not for days but for years
then of course your blood is more
viscous and your you have a whole bunch
of problems associated with the
cardiovascular system so clearly when
you think about humans living at high
altitudes and there are many studies now
there as many of them actually don't
present any sort of sickness their
normal individual so they must be coping
in different ways right so the tree
there are three sort of populations that
have been extensively studied including
by some people in this room The Onion
mountains Tibetans and the Ethiopians
where there are few others and there's
been a lot of work than recently trying
to identify genes that might be helpful
in the
in Indian determining tolerance to these
conditions right so the one thing they
have to remember though is that these
populations are not adapting in in the
same way and this is not only clear from
from the genetics that many of these
people have done but also just by
looking at gross phenotypes and this
this is particularly relevant to us for
chronic mountain sickness so you can see
out here hemoglobin levels and on the
left side you see these plots this is
sea level in the US and it bunches
together very nice leave it Ethiopian in
Tibetan Highlander so if you were to
sample their blood the Hema great count
would be very similar to lowlanders but
if you look at the onion populations
it's not the case and indeed it is the
fact that in a subset of the Indian
populations at least there is chronic
mountain sickness so certainly this is
another good model where we could try
and talk about this now in this stock
because this is more methods based paper
i'll talk more about algorithms and we
will return to some of the results from
both of these datasets but just to hint
at what kind of work what what sort of
the downstream relation of over okay and
i should i should add and disclaimer
when I talk about algorithms because
this is an extended extensively studied
feeling as you know not just like input
it today many people in the audience
have done sort of seminal work in this
so it was indeed with some trepidation
when we look at the data first well you
said let's apply all the different
methods that are out there and it wasn't
clear that we had something new to
contribute but one of the things that
was bothersome is that all of these
methods they work very differently in
different regimes and when you look at
all of these different publications we
will usually apply a bunch of methods
and as long as you meet the cutoff in
one of these methods you should be fine
so there is there certainly some room to
understand why these methods work
differently in different regimes and i
think that's that's where I'd like to
start and again I'm going to start with
some things that are very very basic but
just so that we are all in the same page
so we assume let's say
have a simple right Fisher like model of
constant population and every individual
sort of just takes a parent at random
from the previous generation and then we
also had used the infinite sites models
if there's a mutation it is it is
carried on into the existing generation
unless of course it gets eliminated or
or gets fixed in the population so of
course we don't see the entire genealogy
only the matrix at the end which you can
think of as a binary matrix for now and
then under selection it's the same
process except that when the Selective
constraint it's a player's a beneficial
mutation indicated by star then
certainly that will expand in frequency
and we'll do that very rapidly so the
time to fixations may be like 2n
generations but under fixation it
becomes more like log n generations you
know scaled by the selection parameter
so it's a very quick time to fixation
and as a result the population all looks
alike and and it has any property so if
you throw away the genealogy or the
lineage that died out and just look at
the genealogy clearly there is a
difference and that difference is the
basis for most of the algorithms you can
have you can think in terms of long
haplotypes created by this ancestor
branch lengths the loss of diversity and
so so so really that's that's the
framework in which our own work lies and
let's just talk about let's start with
the allele frequency spectrum although I
I'll have something to say about the
haplotypes as well so if you take this
data set and you can think of the roses
individuals and sizes locations with
let's say zero representing the
ancestral mutation and one representing
the mutant allele and just look at the
frequencies of different spots and then
compute a histogram of the frequencies
the so-called sike frequency spectrum it
looks something like this now the nice
thing is that if you scale if you take
these numbers and actually scale them by
the frequency so you multiply the
frequencies then the plot looks a lot
more uniform and and this is really a
remarkable result classical result in
the
field dutiful which simply says that if
you take the side frequency spectrum and
you scale it by the frequency then in
expectation it's it's the scale mutation
rate so let's start with this plot it's
it's fairly simple to understand and now
let's think about the same thing in
terms of selection so imagine that you
have some time scale and you were to
sample individuals at different times
certainly if it was a neutral population
nothing would change in the side
frequency spectrum but let's say that at
times zero is when the selection
pressure starts right so so now we have
a red plot which shows the allele
frequency spectrum at different times
and even at a time very close to this
time since selection you can see that
there is a significant difference in the
early this is averaged over many samples
of course near fixation you see a very
strong divergence between the blue plot
and the allele the scale allele
frequency spectrum under selection and
this is clearly where most of the
methods seem to work very well and then
over time the plot chips and then maybe
10,000 generations is dr. sloppy
important these these plots probably
merge and then the signals kind of lost
at least in the allele frequency stage
now why is the plot like this I think
it's very easy to understand if you look
at it this way there's a long branch so
it is a long branch which gives you a
whole bunch of high frequency snips and
then there's very quick explosion so you
have a lot of mutations at very low
frequencies and there's a depletion in
the intermediate frequency and so if you
think about tests of selection they are
really trying to find the difference
between these two curves and there's
sort of two scenarios and which people
work on them the so-called cross
population tests where you have two
populations one evolving neutrally and
the other under some kind of non
neutrality or selection and you just try
to find some way of differentiating
between these two curves and then
there's the single population kind of
test where you just look at this
population and see if the curve is
different from expected and a very you
know large number of tests just do
different statistics that is they take
two different estimates of this now one
of the things that is obvious from foods
result is that since each of these
values is an estimate of theta any
linear combination is also an estimate
so if you take two different linear
combinations and you subtract them you
can expectation they would be 0 but by
choosing the weights carefully you can
get that sort of says that you're in
selection and the this is an observation
that I just made that all of the
difference test really the way to think
about them is by looking at the
different weights that you give them and
so the wait for something like that you
must d would be like this as shown here
whereas Fey and goes H would be as shown
over there so now what what's the thing
object this gives us a framework for
understanding when a particular
algorithm is going to work well because
you can already see that if you have a
weights like this and it's like this
they won't always give similar values
especially if you look sort of go back
and you look at the data here in the
early part near fixation because tajima
SD gives a very strong negative value to
the low frequency guys and very small
negative value to the high frequency
ones it will have a very strong negative
signal here not so much for foo which
equally weights this one negatively and
this one positively whereas if you go
out here you can see that tajima's d
will not do as well anymore because
there's a strong negative component here
nothing here whereas Fay & boos
statistic will do much better all right
so so it gives us a framework to
understand how these results would
perform and it's if you do some
simulations you can see the trend pretty
much shows up so these are all different
plots under different selection
constraints here's the time since
election and the dotted line gives the
fixation the fixation time of course
also depends on n and s it's roughly
logarithm of n
their scales by s so something like that
so so you can see out here that faith
and roots does much better than the post
selection regime that is fatima st does
well in the early selection Reggie all
right so yes question what is the size
of the directions you use so I don't
have the numbers of hand but we use what
they do is we do a trick that everybody
does cuz in forward simulation so rather
than taking NS 10,000 we take and as
thousand and then we scale the mutation
and recombination rates I don't have the
numbers of hand but I can I can dig them
out then and find out but we chose
numbers that are sort of you know
standard in the literature I just don't
remember them now just to sort of get to
the punch line you know we can do better
but the idea is very simple once you
understand that you have these weights
and there's a specific regime of wage
that will work well in different
situations well the question you might
ask is why not just drain the weights
that are appropriate for a specific
model so if you are lucky and you knew
what the Selective constraint was s and
what the time since selection was then
we could just sort of create training
data sets where you have these spectral
frequencies spectra from regions under
selection and under neutral evolution
and then just try to figure out what the
optimum weights were of course there are
many many techniques we just used a very
simple technique but in this you can
think of all of these frequency vectors
as points in high-dimensional space and
then the weights just define a
hyperplane and the goal is to find a
hyperplane that best separates these
points so we use support vector machines
but we also tried many other techniques
and interestingly they all seem to give
very similar results of the data that we
have so so in this case you know when we
try this of course you know we have a
different data set trained for every
specific regime we end up sort of
dominating the spectrum and you can see
that indeed there is a decay in power
but the power to select is much much
better than what we could have now of
course we are cheating because we have
access to all of these the scale
coefficients and also the times and
selection what if we didn't have that so
we there of course other direct ways of
estimating that we went with something
very simple we said let's look at the
weights that we have learned and try to
see if there's some relationship between
the way so what we can do is on this
plot or what we do is let's take a
specific selection coefficient these are
sort of all the weights learned for
different times in selection and we
compare the weights learn against
themselves and if you look at the scale
you can see that the set of weights fall
very nicely into two blocks one sort of
in the post fixation regime and run in
the near fixation the pre very early
stages there's very little signal so
that looks very nice because it suggests
that we don't need these you know a very
very large number of models we could do
with very few number of models and when
you apply this to different a set of
selection pressures and different
selection times the whole structure is
completely maintained you can see that
the time to fixation is shifting as you
go from very high selection coefficients
to very low selection coefficients but
still the post selection and the
pre-selection and the near selection
regimes remain fixed it suggests that a
relatively small number of models can
still explain explain this data all
right so we did something very simple
almost sort of first principles we just
took two we took collected all of our
data sets and train something for near
fixation and then we collected the data
sets for post fixation and we train them
and our statistic was simply the maximum
of the discrimination for either of them
and that again turns out to do quite
well it's sort of beats other methods
but it also gives us a framework in
which we can now if you want say in the
post-election we have a lot of room for
improvement it tells us some directions
in which we can go right now we can also
do this for cross population test and in
this case we have say if you have a
match
population certainly we had that in the
fly case but often in human cases people
do look at some neighboring population
and will instead of looking at just the
allele frequency spectrum we can look
sort of a two-dimensional a little
frequency spectrum so you take the same
site in two locations and compute the
Joint Distribution of their frequencies
and and then the end the spectrum out of
that and now if you have this analogous
version of the scaled side frequency for
pairs of frequencies you can learn
pretty much the same vector weights and
try to discriminate between selection
and non selection and again we tried
this approach and it does well both in
the sort of specific case where we of
course quickly dominate everything else
but also in the in the in the case where
we only train two models and now we
compare against other cross population
test the eh etches an extension of the
homozygote extended homozygote that it
has to do with the haplotype length of
haplotype sorry and then the composite
likely test you too Nick Patterson and
they look like so so certainly there is
I think we can summarize and say that
while there still room for improvement
in the test it does look like there's a
fair amount of work that you can do with
very simple vectors just based on
looking at allele frequencies and so on
so the question that we asked ourselves
our next was well you know there are
many other selection regimes there are
also different demographic scenarios but
I'm going to skip that for now there's
so called a multilocus election where
you have a lot of alleles at different
locations which jointly a might offer
confer selective advantage and that
becomes much harder and I won't have
much to say about it today but I want to
say a few words about soft so even this
is sort of more unpublished work up to
right so so consider a situation where
the beneficial allele was already exists
extending the population
when when selection happened so this is
the so called a heart sweet case where
the beneficial allele is at very low
frequencies when the selective
constraint appeared and here we can see
a quick exponential growth in alleles
carrying this beneficial early now here
in the soft selection we have a
different scenario because the
beneficial allele was already existing
in the population and so it was sort of
the haplotypes carrying this allele were
drifting around and there's a fair
amount of variation that they may have
inherited and then once selected
pressures are occurred they sort of grow
exponentially but they compete with each
other because they are more or less
equally fit and then they out-compete
other plates and my other lineages that
might not not carry the beneficial away
so the signal therefore is a somewhat
muted and and we would still like to be
able to detect it all right so now we
have this additional parameter F which
is the frequency of of the beneficial
allele at the time of selection right so
too in order to handle these cases we
sort of go back to the literature and
look at a haplotype based test if you
think about hard sweeps people often
look for a dominant haplotype and it is
often represented by this ancestral
branch here and so if you can capture
this there's fairly there's not enough
mutations here so this diversity is
maintained and many of these tests like
IHS try to capture this and if you look
at neutral populations there is a fair
amount of diversity so you wouldn't see
a single haplotype sort of sweeping the
surface now this is we cannot really
expect the same thing in soft selection
so one might consider the haplotype
frequency spectrum and indeed there's a
recent paper from the petroglyph which
instead of taking the dominant haplotype
takes the top two dominant haplotypes
and they come up with a statistic that
seems to do well in these circumstances
right so we asked this question well how
can we improve the or how can we predict
a shift in the haplotype frequency
spectrum
relative to the neutral Elaine so what
what you want to do in order to sort of
strengthen the signal is to be able to
eliminate these recent polymorphisms
because they kind of add noise if you
could eliminate them then you get a
stronger shift in the hybrid i freaking
because only the dominant haplotypes
remain all of these guys become
identical out here so if we could
somehow eliminate these snares without
necessarily eliminating the low
frequency snips in the neutrally
evolving population that should
strengthen the result it should make the
shift more pronounced and this is the
problem that we sort of grapple with a
little bit now there again with all of
these things there are many ways to
approach this you might consider the
sort of building make you know
approximations to the coalescent and
actually figuring out which mutations
are the early ones sort of like a hit
where the haplotypes are or you might
try to do something like i HS which just
looks starts from a particular location
and then just looks at the decay in the
haplotype frequency and use that as a
statistic what we do is we want to try
and eliminate these low frequency guys
so that the high frequency ones
automatically eliminate so so we come up
with this sort of fancy sound sounding
title but really it's something very
simple so you take you start with any
node and you give it the weight of the
sub tree at that node and then the note
here has the weight of the sub tree at
that node and so on till you go down to
the haplotype right and then the cfp of
this haplotype is just the two norm of
that vector now that vector will look
very different for things that are under
hard sweep soft wheat and neutral
evolving here you can see that there are
a lot of medium frequency guys so the
cfp value will be somewhat mid in the
middle here you'll have very high cfp
value so here you'll have very high cfp
values because all of these nodes have
the entire subtree as their sub have the
entire tree as their sub tree right so
so the cfp can help distinguish between
mutations that are the bottom waves
without eliminating the mutations that
might be under neutral selection and so
now we have these two facets we have the
frequency of the allele itself and we
have its CFP by the way the CFP of a
variant would be just the average of the
CFP of all the haplotypes are carrying
it like alright so so here's sort of
just a plot of a single example though
you know we can see similar results with
expected with expectations over many
samples here in the middle the plus
symbols are we're in neutral evolving on
the inside so they have medium values of
C FPS and medium values of frequencies
but for something under selection and
this is with a soft selection scenario
where the initial frequency was about
point three the situation is quite
different so in the beginning they all
look matched up with the neutral alleles
and now the alleles begin to shift and
so you will see a lot of sniffs that
carry on with the beneficial allele in
star and that sort of moving on towards
high frequency and high cfp values and
they go all the way to the top right and
sort of disappear and then the early
snips they have this other property that
they have high cfp values but low
frequencies and so they keep moving in
the top quadrant till the time where the
beneficial allele disappears and now
suddenly they will shift because we no
longer have them here so they little
chip to having low cfp values because
the the nodes carrying the high sub
trees have disappeared so if we
eliminated these two quadrants and we
use another sort of machine learning
technique to find the best separators
but what I won't go into here we can
actually eliminate the recent snips with
which it might be in selected scenarios
without eliminating any of the mutations
in the neutral alleles and so if you do
this elimination you end up seeing a
very strong signal in the frequency
spectrum so here we have the haplotype
frequency spectrum and not surprisingly
most of the appli types of air
low frequencies and there's very little
distinction between something evolving
neutrally and something under sweet are
even if you go from hundred generations
to fifty five hundred thousand
generations at different generations if
you apply a filter just based on
frequencies you begin to see some
difference and now if you apply a filter
based on both frequencies and cfps you
see you begin to see a very very strong
difference in these selections right so
it's a way of getting at the haplotypes
that are core to the to the to the
selection without actually having to
compute Nikolas in itself right and not
surprisingly we also have good power
it's not as good as in the hard sweep
case but we have we do have good power
here for comparison we have the IHS test
in the h1 to which at least in our hands
didn't seem to perform that well okay so
just a summary is that early results do
show some promise and detecting soft
sweet but we still have a lot of work to
do to be able to distinguish soft whip
scenarios from hearts which currently
they were just working on seeing if we
could detect whether the region was
under non neutrality or not in the
presence of soft see right and the other
thing that's somewhat unclear although
identically show our data for this is
that it's not clear that the haplotype
frequency spectrum really is a better
discriminator than psych frequency
spectrum even in the soft okay so even
though we use that to motivate our talk
in in experimental data it seems like
the there's more signal in the side
frequency spectrum even in this even in
the soft visionary alright so I want to
just end with some experimental data
then this is not involving the soft
sweet scenario we haven't really tried
that on a lot of experimental data but
just the hard sleep so in the flight
case we found exactly two regions and
you can see that the signal with whole
genome and I'll have a little bit more
to say about this in a minute is quite
strong in a few regions
and moreover in this case they had
replicate populations so you have the
opportunity to see whether the different
independently evolving populations found
the same regions under selection or not
and and it turns out that they do very
nicely here we took the same statistic
and just inverted it to show one
population here in one population here
and you can see that the regions that
sort of go beyond our false discovery
rate cut off are exactly matched up and
in fact even elsewhere they seem to be
very nicely matched up and then there
just happened to be two regions with
close to 188 gene so these are you know
largest regions with which are gene rich
but they seem to be having the signal
for selection what you can do in the
Flies of course is that you can do
additional experiments and in many cases
we did some knockdown experiments and
identify many of the genes especially
genes in the notch pathway that that
seemed to be under selection pressure
and with the application of the new
statistic we found very interesting
result so first we matched up all of the
results that we had before which did you
know the matchup was very good but in
addition notch itself which is of course
you know one of the key components of
the notch pathway also happens to show a
cig signature of selection so that is an
exciting discovery something that we are
following up in the lab now okay now we
do the same thing for the human data but
in this in this case we don't have a
control population that's available to
us so we did look at a few related
populations we did a quick test of
admixture and we find that our sort of
andean populations look somewhat more
similar to the MXL mexicans in LA so go
figure and and and we took as a out
group and African population which
seemed to be very different in
population so we have the three clades
with we also do three population test so
we have the the Highlanders the CMS and
non CMS in the Highlanders
then the Lowlander controls and and also
an out-group now one of the questions
that people often ask is you know well
how many individuals we did very few
individuals it's still expensive we only
did sort of 10 in 10 each 10 in with CMS
stand without CMS and so this was really
a question for us should we go with
whole genome sequencing in sort of
sample all sites or or go with with few
sites and maybe use arrays or exome
sequencing or one of the less expensive
technologies and I'd like to make a plug
so one of the things that you can get
with whole genome sequencing is that you
can get a much much denser spectrum of
of populations and here's some data to
show how that works out so one of the
regions that we find on chromosome 90
has a very very strong signal for us
here are the non CMS individuals and you
can see that there's a whole bunch of
haplotypes at very similar frequency
frequency suggesting a rise in haplotype
frequency here here we have a much
bigger variation and so this is this
gives a very nice signal now if you look
at the same data with genotyping they're
just too few snips to really make a call
and it's not easy when you're talking
about populations like this to do an
imputation because you are really
there's a selection bias and ascertain
meant bias in how the control
populations are selected so if you use
those the thousand genomes to impute
populations that are in the Highlanders
we have some sort of data that's not on
this talk but I can show it to you later
which suggests that imputation
techniques wouldn't work in this case so
we get this we also have similar results
with exome sequencing with their very
few data sets so we applied a whole
bunch of different techniques to this
and I'll just sort of zoom in on the
same region that I showed on another
sense different chromosome 12 region
this one came up with a with two three
genes of interest and it was sort of
region under you can see that there is a
very strong frequency differential which
suggests that this region might be sorry
of intro
alright so the genes are interesting but
they also give us another sort of
perspective on how we can do these
experiments because in this case we also
collected our collaborators also
corrected fibroblast so so we have in
potential we can convert them to IPS
season they're doing that and then
convert them to pretty much any tissue
type and that allows us to measure gene
expression and their variety of
scenarios but the data here is just for
fibroblasts and once you take these sort
of cell lines and now you put them under
hypoxia you do see reduced expression of
certain genes of these two genes not not
the third one and that suggests that a
lowered expression which is consistent
with with our sort of genetic data is is
indeed important for for hypoxia
tolerance now you can take the same
genes and you can take their normal
locks and knock them down in drosophila
where we have a lot of RNAi
intermediates and certainly if you put
them in normal oxygen they seem to have
regular expression patterns but but I
mean sorry they have to seem to have
high survival rates but under hypoxia
when these jeans are interfered with and
their expression is reduced the survival
is greatly enhanced whereas when the
knockdown isn't there and the genes are
active in the survival is low so we can
go sort of all the way from our
predictions to experiment in this
particular situation all right so I'd
like to sort of just conclude here by
saying that indeed whole genome
sequences are useful when you're
identifying signatures of selection the
density of data that you get is very
important for the algorithms to work
that there is still room for algorithmic
improvement as i showed in the first
part of my talk and now with sort of
newer techniques there is we have the
potential to go all the way from our
predictions down to the two experiments
in the lab so it's it's good news all
around and just to acknowledge Roy and
Nathan are the grad students in my lab
who did pretty much all of the work and
of course this is a big collaborative
project so Gabby Haddad was our main
operator and he and Enzo in his lab did
all of the experimental work that that I
am showing here the the work on
selection was in collaboration with Iran
who's in the audience and they work on
soft sweeps is in collaboration with
Noah Rosenberg at Stanford all right
thank you any questions have you
estimated the sensitivity of your
methods to balance election to
background selection yeah I'm sorry I
don't know what is happening by
consulate it's when you have a
deleterious are you that increase is a
bit in frequency but then disappears and
takes away I prototypes with it aha you
also skews the sad frequency spectrum I
have we have not tested in that
particular scenario it's a good question
maybe we can talk offline so that there
wasn't really any more information in
the haplotypes spectrum than in the low
frequency spectrum I mean it seems hard
to believe that you know cos theory is
there there's a ton more information
that you're saying it's not there's not
more useful information there tonight
yeah of course I mean some of it is you
know how what our experiments revealed
but I mean in general yes there is when
you use haplotypes but you have to
remember that if you have it's somewhat
data-dependent to if you take a much
larger spectrum of haplotypes you might
be able to get finer differences in
haplotype frequencies but the other
thing is that you have to do a very
careful job as as the you know as the
evolution happens even rare variants
will change haplotype so what does it
mean for two haplotypes to be identical
or very similar to each other we use the
specific filtering technique to filter
out the haplotypes but in our hands once
you do that the allele frequency
spectrum just as good a job better job
of discriminating then the haplotype
frequency spectrum but that's not to say
that you know everything
that we could say has been and
everything that one could say as me I
saw some other engines yes sister Jaya
sequence by regulation size yes we did
do a test under a bunch of demographic
scenarios I don't know let me see if I
have a slide I am this is one of the
ones that we did so it's just you know
to take drama truthful kind of
experiment where there's a bottleneck
and so is the African and European
population they also tried a bunch of
other scenarios I think the results are
more or less similar to what we have
before in the sense that remember we
have one series of tests that are really
specific to the data set train and so if
you take a population sample changing
data from this and you train then you
will get excellent results and then if
you take a more generic model and you
apply then you still get good results
but with refuse power so so the story
doesn't change but we did try a few at
the the problem though is that you don't
know which one just apply except in
cases where you know something about the
demographics and you're confident
applying a specific okay so